[MUSIC]
Good evening everyone and welcome.
I'm Garth Saloner.
I'm the dean of the Graduate School of
Business.
On behalf of the GSB I'd like to welcome
you all to this event this evening.
This is the 37th Annual Encore Award
Dinner.
Each year the award is given to the
entrepreneurial company of
the year which demonstrates the spurt
innovation and culture of
the companies that have been springing up
in Silicon Valley since the late 1970s.
I'm delighted to congratulate Netflix and
CEO Reed Hastings who's MS 88 on being the
recipient of the award this evening.
Please join me in giving him a round of
applause.
[APPLAUSE].
I'd like to give a special thanks to the
encore selection committee for
their work in selecting this year's
winner.
I'd also like to thank all of the sponsors
for tonight's event.
In addition to welcoming many of our GSB
alumni here this evening we have a number
of engineering school alums and I welcome
you to this event as well.
Entrepreneurship is thriving at Stanford
University and
including of course the Graduate School of
Business.
While we don't have final numbers for
the current years class in the class the
year before, almost one
in five of our graduates started their own
company straight out of business school.
So that's for those of you who know what
these trends look like a big
increase from, from prior years and, and
very much a, an upward trend over time.
In addition to that another,
about quarter of the class took jobs in
the technology sector.
So if you put those together and then you
add, finance jobs in, in tech,
it's almost 50 or 60% of the class, going
into technology at the moment.
We have not seen, numbers like that since
1999.
[LAUGH] And I'm just saying you know,
make of that what you will.
We continue to innovate ourselves in, in
entrepreneurship and
I'd like to share with you just a couple
of examples of, of things we've
done recently to be entrepreneurial
ourselves on the global front.
Last week we launched a, a section of our
course which is called start-up garage.
and, what differentiated the course this
year is we offered it, in a classroom that
we have in the night management center
which is a highly immersive classroom.
Half of the classroom is here on the
Stanford campus.
The other half of the classroom,
which you see through a screen in front of
you is in Beijing.
And, and the class was taught as a, as a
combined class of Stanford students and
students from Peking University who were
combining in multidisciplinary fashion
around start up ideas across, across two
different continents.
So that's I think, a sign of the times.
The other example I would give you is a,
is a program we call Stanford Ignite.
Stanford Ignite started as a program we
used to call the Summer Internship for
Entrepreneurship for those of you who
remember SIE.
That was a program that we offered at the
Business School for
Graduate students at Stanford who were not
in the business school.
The idea being if you have something great
in the lab, it,
it might be a good idea to get a little
bit of the management on the way out and
we've now taken that program globally.
And again that's a program we're able to,
to offer globallour faculty out in
most instances from the ny because we
[UNKNOWN] ight management center into
wherever they are and we started a program
last week again in, in Beijing.
We've had a program going for about a
month in Santiago, Chile.
We've been in Bangalore, India for several
years.
We've been in Paris for a few years.
We we will go to Sao Paulo and New York
City next year.
And so that's another example of how
we're, we're able to increase our
region in entrepreneurship thanks to
thanks to the educational technology.
In all of these activities whether they
are here or
abroad we we rely on the ecosystem that
we're, we're a part of.
People come into our classes they, they
mentor students,
they they help advise students in a, in a
variety of ways.
They're guest speakers, we write cases on
them so,
we couldn't do what we, what we do without
this ecosystem that we're part of.
And so I wanted to thank all of you for
whatever you do to,
to help us in those endeavors.
So, thank you very much.
And with that, it's my, it's my great
pleasure to invite up
Jeff Yang co founder and partner at, at
Red Point Ventures.
Jeff is a, is an MBA from our class of 85
and
the Chairman of the Encore Award Selection
Committee.
Please join me in in welcoming Jeff to the
stand.
[APPLAUSE].
>> Thank you everybody.
And on behalf of the Encore Selection
Committee,
well wanna welcome you to the tonight's
award night.
So a question might come up,
why would you pick a 17-year-old company
to win the entrepreneur of the year award.
Well, the answer's easy.
The name of the award is the
Entrepreneurial Company of the Year,
not the youngest public company of the
year.
And as you'll hear later, Netflix we
think, is,
is one of the most amazing companies cuz
it's gone through so
many different iterations to get to where
it is now.
And I can't imagine that even someone as
visionary as
Reed Hastings could ever have imagined
running in a,
an Emmy-award winning content company when
he first started Netflix in 1997.
And that's really why we chose Netflix.
Netflix has gone through many iterations
to
to where it's gotten now to where it is
now.
And we chose them for their constant
reinvention and entrepreneurial spirit.
We believe that a company can be
entrepreneurial regardless of
its age since inception.
And we think Netflix is the prime example
of that.
So without further ado, I'm going to run a
short reel telling you a little about
Netflix, get you all excited, and then
we'll bring up its founder, Reed Hastings.
[NOISE].
>> Who doesn't love a great story, from
heartwarming.
>> Did you think I'd forgotten you?
>> To bone chilling.
From don't tell me what happens, to I
can't wait for what happens next.
From that first big moment, to just one
more,
to just one more, to just, one, more.
[MUSIC]
We create great stories for pure,
uninterrupted enjoyment.
[MUSIC]
>> So that the way we watch will never be
the same.
>> That's what I'm talking about.
[MUSIC]
This is story telling as it was meant to
be.
[MUSIC]
>> Hey Reed if you, need an agent Frank
Underwood for next season I'm available.
I'd like to bring up Reed Hastings who is
the founder of Netflix.
He founded Netflix in 1997.
But if you go way back to when Reed
received his BA from Boden,
he spent a couple of years [INAUDIBLE]
serving in the Peace Corps as
a high school math teacher before coming
to Stanford to receive a masters in AI.
After that he went to go work in the AI
lab at Schlumberger.
Spent a couple of years at a failed
startup in the AI space called
Coherent Thought before moving for
a very short time to another early stage
company called Adaptive and
then ultimately started his first company,
Pure Software in 1991.
Took it public in 1995.
And and then finally it was acquired in
1997 by Rational Software.
That was the year Reed founded Netflix.
One of the things that you,
you might think, is that, wow, that's a, a
classic example of a serial entrepreneur.
But I really think of a serial
entrepreneur is
somebody who starts a company, leaves,
starts another company, and then leaves.
Reed is really kind of the serial founder
and
if Pure hadn't been sold he might well
still be founder there.
But for the last 17 years he has been
founder and
CEO of Netflix, please join me in
welcoming Reed Hastings.
[APPLAUSE]
[SOUND].
>> Reed brought, brought his tissue box in
case his starts-
>> Starts tearing up [CROSSTALK].
>> Yeah.
So let, let me first start by asking you,
you know, how,
how does it feel to be here?
You have some familiarity with the award.
>> It, it is extraordinary because I was
gonna give the dean a hard time
because when I was a computer science
graduate student here, I tried so
hard to cross-list [COUGH] in the business
school to do the entrepreneurial course,
and was turned down.
so, it is, it's very sweet to be here
tonight.
>> My guess is if you apply again you'll
get in.
>> Yeah, I'll try, we'll see.
We'll see.
And
then, when I started Pure in 91, the,
then,
venture capitalist Andy Radcliff took me
to this event, and I remember so amazing.
And over at the Menlo Circus Club and
I was a engineer in a t-shirt with a new
product and and here was,
you know the Stanford Business School, the
warden Filipe Khan had won that year.
And did an amazing presentation and
is you know full of life and it was just
incredible.
And so when I heard that Netflix had got
it this year it was very, very touching.
>> Well, we, your, it's, it's very
well-deserved.
Maybe you can spend a couple minutes
talking about Netflix and you,
you know, most people many entrepreneurs
start with, in one area and
one discipline and kind of linearly
progress to the other.
I mean you started a, a design tools
company and then an entertainment company.
Talk a little bit about where the lines
fit or
don't fit and what was your thinking when
you first started the company?
>> well, the first company, Pure Software,
was a unit software tools company and
it got acquired and then you got a long
waiting period regulatory period.
And so, my co founder Marc Randolph and
I were kicking around you know, various
ideas on what to do.
One of them was rental.
And a third friend of ours told us about
DVD.
And I remember thinking back a DVD is very
lightweight and
it's five gigabytes of digital data.
And I remember going back to the original
networking classes that I'd
taken in CS and realizing that, you know,
five gigabytes mailing could be a very
efficient digital distribution network.
And so from the very beginning we always
thought about it as you know,
waiting to complete the last leg.
That we had the web interface and building
up a subscriber base on DVD.
And then eventually the Internet would be
fast enough to be able to not be dependent
on the post office but be dependent, you
know, instead on the Internet.
So, it was there right from the beginning
which is I joke that
that's why we named it Netflix and not
dvdbymail.com.
And and there are real companies in the
world called like dvdposts.com.
They will have a harder time moving into
streaming.
>> [LAUGH] So you started the company in
97 in
Scotts Valley with people stuffing DVDs in
envelopes.
And now you're streaming videos on a
worldwide basis.
Talk a little bit about, you know, the
challenges, the different stages between,
between then and now and some of the
challenges you've faced along the way.
>> Well the first big challenge was
getting the profitability and
stop consuming cash.
And DVD rental's very cash consumptive cuz
you have to market or
acquire customers that pay back over time
and you have to buy DVDs,
which then pay back over time, and so it's
very cash intensive.
And we underestimated you know,
having been software marketing people that
the logistic challenges and
it took us you know, years of working on
the red envelope that you now see.
Went through, you know, 50 different
variations of the red envelope and,
and scale testing and
we learned more about polycarbonates under
stress than you ever wanna learn.
And, you know, it was really
understanding, you know,
the shipping a disc of plastic for a long
time.
It took us five years till 2002 to break
even.
And the, about cash flow will break even
also.
So that was the first big milestone.
We went public that year.
Same week there was a little brief window.
Us and PayPal and Overstock all went
public in one week.
>> At what price?
>> The window was closed.
7.50 in today's terms.
We're now about 450.
7.50 versus 450.00.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Good distinction.
>> And yeah, just to be clear so
then that, that was the first stage second
stage
Blockbuster realized after we went public
that we were gonna be a real threat.
And they geared up an effort.
They launched in 2004 and
from 2004 to 2007 we had a very fun, scary
epic battle with Blockbuster.
They had a huge advantage, they were you
know 15 or 20 times larger than us.
But we had the advantage that we had
started it.
And really if they had started two years
earlier they probably would have won.
You know, in perfect hindsight.
Because they would have just or
in those messy execution they would have
overwhelmed us.
And the other thing is when Viacom spun
them out,
it saddled them with a billion dollars in
debt with a lot of tough covenants.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And
if they had instead given them a billion
in cash, they might have had enough power.
So, you know, it's a miraculous that we
lived.
But then, you know, we beat Blockbuster.
And they ultimately went bankrupt, because
video store economics.
You can imagine a single unit store on
half the volume you get you know,
negative profit so.
>> It doesn't work very well, that's why
that industry collapsed.
No sooner had we finished that great
victorious battle,
that we were the winners and DVD and
wasn't this going to be great.
When YouTube was born and streaming
started actively.
So we launched our first streaming product
in 2007, but it wasn't very interesting.
Didn't have much content, it was only on
Windows PCs, it was very small scale.
And then we just kept working at it.
And we finally got the Starz deal, which
was a epic deal to be able to carry.
All the, the Starz movies.
>> Hm-mm.
>> And got the Xbox deal to get on the TV,
that was in 2008 and then the thing really
started taking off.
And then we finished, finished, but we got
ahead in streaming and
we were still a domestic business.
Now this was 2010, so we've been 13 years
just in the US to get to streaming.
But now with streaming, you know, we could
expand internationally without having to
deal with, you know, British post and
Canada post and, you know, French post.
So we started that expansion very actively
in the last four years which is
going from a domestic company to global
and it's hard.
Right.
You've got a lot of
things that you didn't realize that are
very locked into domestic after 13 years.
And then the expansion into new and
original content, which is like other,
other cable networks.
So if you look at FX, if you look at HBO,
AMC.
They all start on other people's license
content and
then try their hand at producing original
content.
And so that's been obviously a huge
success for us.
So the, the big hard challenges over the
next five and
ten years are getting more global and
getting more into original content.
So we're working on both of those.
>> Is it hard to convince the original on
your first studio deals?
How hard was it to convince them that, you
know, streaming was going to be okay and
that their rights would be protected?
And that there was an economic model for
them, cuz you really changed the way they
think about their business, right?
>> Yeah.
The very early deals were with
minimum guarantees to them that killed us,
but, you know, we just had to pay it.
But then we were able to grow out of that.
And of course, they had seen the movie and
television business had seen the music
business.
So they knew keeping the head in the sand
was not the right approach.
They, they built their own pay-per-view
service, an iTunes competitor called
Movie Link and they started that in 2001,
way before there was a market.
And so, you know, that media group, movies
and
TVs did not want to be like the brothers
in the music business.
So there was a lot of motivation to
experiment and, and
then we became another bidder, where we
bid against HBO.
And so the artists do better, because it's
raising the price.
The con, content owners do better because
we're another bidder.
>> They probably at, at first thought that
you were the the devil and
now you're, you're the knight in shining
armor with the big checkbook.
>> And they still think we're the,
they always want more, you know, it's a
normal supplier relationship.
And now, you know,
with originals were sort of going around
them to developing brands on our own.
And the big difference with original
content it's still a third
party that's actually on set and on
location.
And we're not on set that much but we do
the brand creation when it launches.
So you have to take something like Orange
Is the New Black, which is unknown or
Marco Polo that we have coming out in
December and it's an unknown series and
then make it really big and give it.
So the big change is us launching,
creating global brands.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then it's a mix of the talent, you
know,
the history, the storyline, all that.
>> So how did you decide to, to get into
content?
You know, up to this point you're really
primarily a distribution company.
Is it a hard leap to go on a content and,
and
how did you convince your board that it
was the right idea?
>> Yeah one of our long term executives
been with us since 2000,
Ted Sarandos really gets all the credit
for it.
He's the one who talked the rest of us
that here's what cable networks do and
look at this, and how they grow into
originals.
And back in 2010 is when we launched our
commission, the first one,
House of Cards, which is even before the
whole quick start incident.
And so, it definitely helped us.
>> Mm-hm.
>> but, they're, they're long legs so it
was,
you know, four years ago when we had to
make the decision on, on House of Cards.
>> All right.
And your success rate's quite high.
I mean, you've had 31 nominations 7
Emmy's.
And last year alone, you had 14
nominations and 3 Emmy's.
I mean, by any metric a very high hit
rate, you know?
What's your secret and, and what are you
gonna do when you've gotta flop?
>> I am, you know, look, if we don't push
hard enough, you know?
We should, we need to have a flop every
now and then.
You know, it's somewhat the advantage of
being on a demand creation platform.
And so Hemlock Row, we just commissioned
season three.
Lilyhammer, we did season three.
So we've never had a cancelled series in
our history.
You know, we've ended some in season three
as opposed to carrying it for, for,
you know, five or ten seasons.
But it wraps up nicely in the storyline.
The, you know, consumers are not left
hanging of you know, like Jericho or
Firefly or these things.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So we're really excited by that track
record.
But a lot of the advantage is because
we're online and,
you know, its just much more flexible as
all of you know that are members.
Cuz you can choose to watch when and how
you want.
>> And how did you decide to go into
content?
I mean, what, what, what was the, what
would you,
what did you hope to achieve by going in?
>> It's a moving of the brand when you're
not doing original content, you're,
you're just iTunes.
I mean, you carry other people's content
and you don't even have a full selection.
And, you know, it's a commodity
relationship.
You know, you subscribe to Netflix if it's
the lowest, cheapest price.
And then when you develop a new brand like
Orange is the New Black,
then people talk about it.
The brand's closely associated.
They join, because of the show.
It's a much stronger and you've created
that brand.
So you, you own the brand equity in that.
So it's it's a much stronger relationship
with key content.
And then, you know, next year, we have an
amazing new set of shows in addition to
additional seasons that our current show
is coming out.
So it just builds on itself.
>> Hm.
That's great.
Did you, did you,
were there any success models you were
looking at in terms of developing content?
And, and how do you decide which,
how many pieces of content to develop and
what is a good brand?
>> [COUGH] Ted's team analyzes lots of
data and
then at the day has to make a gut call
based upon the team that's together on it,
how they think about it, does he have a
good feeling about it?
But ultimately, it's a, it's a gut call.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And
then we're able to use differential
information to successfully promote that
series to the right people, because almost
no series is good for everybody.
So we've got tremendous leverage in
creating consumption and
enjoyment of content.
But in the upfront commissioning process
it's, you know,
not hugely different from the kind of
people that do it at, at HBO and FX.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We tend, we tend to trust the artists
more.
We tend to work by the freedom and
responsibility model more and
they like that.
But so for the artist point of view, we've
got a great reputation.
>> Hm.
So before we go back and, and, and talk a
little bit more about a little bit
about management style, you know stay on
the content for a second.
You, you kind of created this concept of
binge viewing that, that seemingly has,
has altered people's the way people
consume content.
>> Yeah.
>> Can you talk a little bit
more about that?
What do you, how did you decide, did you
plan for that?
And, and how do you exploit that and?
>> No, really binge viewing, we
counter-planned on it,
because we tried to kill the term.
because, you know, binge is associated
with, you know, negative things really.
And we thought this wasn't good.
And what we didn't realize is that the
term would come to be
gentler interpreted and the fact that it
was a little bit aggressive [UNKNOWN],
you know, catch fire.
But in the first real binge viewing was
DVD.
TV sets on DVD and people would get
Sopranos and
The Wire and Mad Men on DVD and watched
ten episodes.
So that we felt the behavior just on DVD
shipments going to TV series.
And then when you brought that online, it
really accelerated it.
And, you know, when you think about it
when you buy a book, you know, ten or
fifteen chapters in a book.
Then it's not remarkable that you're
allowed to read three chapters one night,
one the next night and five chapters the
next night.
>> Yeah.
>> You know,
that basic thing of human control of
watching on your schedule,
instead of on the programmer schedule.
In hind sight, it's pretty basic.
So linear TV as we know it will be as much
as a relic in 20 years as
the fixed line telephone, you know, like
some of your parents will still have one.
But, you know, most people it, you know,
it's, it's pretty irrelevant for.
>> Right.
So, so let's, let's talk a little bit
about management style and philosophy.
And, you know, yours is seemingly has
changed and
evolved over the years, you know?
If you don't mind, talk a little bit about
that.
You know, you spec especially talk about
your concept of freedom of responsibility.
>> Yeah, up until 2002, all we focused on
was survival.
And then once we got public and, and
we're profitable we started thinking, wow,
this thing might last.
And the, the cruelest irony would be to
not want to work there.
You know to let it become a place we
didn't want to be.
And so we tried to think through what do
we really care about?
We realized what we really care about is
working with incredible people on
hard problems and that, that was the
essence.
So we should organize everything around
supporting that of working with, you know,
just incredibly talented people.
And so that led us to freedom and
responsibility, because incredible people
don't wanna be micro managed.
And the idea is that manage through
setting context and letting people run.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You've gotta have the right people,
you gotta reinforce that with values set a
context about what the company is
trying to achieve.
But the idea to build a system where
amazing amounts of
service improvement happened In the
marketing, in the content,
in the technology in the user interface
without direct intervention of me.
And so some companies operate by, you
know, the product genius at the top and
we all know, these companies and this
whole motif of, you know,
to be a great CEO, you've gotta be the
great product person who really, you know,
and it's intoxicating and fun.
But you're building incredible amounts of
dependence on yourself.
And eventually, you know, how will I know
how Turkish consumers consume Netflix?
It's not that well.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so
you're much stronger, obviously building a
distributed set of great thinkers.
People know that, but
in the past what they've done is try to
make everything a process.
They said, okay.
I don't want it to be a genius, so we're
gonna organize a process for everything.
And just once in awhile, you heard we're
gonna dummy proof it,
it's gonna be such a good process that
anybody, that was the idea [UNKNOWN].
And then if you dummy proof the process,
you only get dummies to work there,
you know, to do the process.
And so that's why we're so, you know,
opposed to that.
Instead so focused on giving people great
freedom, realizing there'll be mistakes.
But there'll be a lot of positive
achievement too.
>> So, can you give some examples of that?
I mean, you know, you talk about it
generically and it sounds great, but
what are some specific examples?
>> Yeah.
So I, I, I take pride in making as few
decisions as possible as opposed to as
many as possible.
And so when something significant changes
in the content or
the House of Cards purchase, you know, Ted
explained it.
It was a huge purchase at that time.
It was a half an hour conversation, you
know, we went back and forth.
I said, are you really sure it's a great
bet?
Yes.
Let's do it.
You know, it wasn't like me reading the
script and
me meeting with Kevin Spacey, and you
know?
>> Mm-hm.
>> or, equivalent examples on the
marketing or
equivalent examples on the product in the
evolution there.
So it, it's creating a sense of I, I wanna
make a difference and
I can make a difference.
And if that's what the leader gets excited
about is that other
people are making a difference and you've
got the right people.
You gotta be super demanding, so
the, you know, one part is freedom and
responsibility.
The other part is a high performance
culture.
Where we say adequate performance, gets a
generous severance package.
And so, you know, we look at it we wanna
be like a Major League Baseball team and,
you know, you've only got so many
positions in the field.
And if everyone is not incredible at what
they do, then you're not gonna win.
>> So you turn over a lot of people.
>> And so we turn over a lot of people.
We feel like, you know, we, we give people
a fair shot and, you know, we,
we hire pretty openly.
And they know what they're getting into.
But we're looking for people who, for whom
freedom and
responsibility works, cuz they do
incredible work.
Hm.
So if you don't make that many decisions
is would be okay if
they the board paid you on a number of
decisions made basis?
>> Yes.
[LAUGH].
>> So the, now, now that you're, you're a
global you know, you're scaling on a,
on a global basis and you're, you're
moving into content that's did.
Does your management philosophy change
going forward?
I mean, is there, is there new thought
that you've had?
>> No, there's little issues, like we have
thing about no vacation policy and,
you know, we don't care whether you work
eight hours or
fourteen hours a day, we care what you get
done.
And we love someone who's working five
hours a day and gets done a ton.
But this runs afoul [COUGH] like a French
law and cultural expectations.
So if you've got employees in France, like
what do you mean there's no vacation?
You know, it's illegal.
And so yeah, we're, you know, we're having
to make some
adjustments to European sensibilities so
there's some things.
>> So, so let's, let's talk, let's look a
little bit into the future now and
talk a little bit about, you know?
Describe to, to us, if you will, what type
of work you're doing to moderni,
to envision and then moderize the,
modernize the TV viewing experience.
What is it gonna look like, you know, ten
or
twenty years to, to this concept of
watching TV?
>> Well, it's evolving rapidly to be,
it'll all be internet centric.
So obviously, movies and TV shows will be
purely on demand.
News is 24 hours, happens all the time.
You know that'll be on demand.
And then sports is one of the most
interesting.
We won't do sports, but other people will.
And then, you know, there's the whole what
team are you rooting for.
There's the, all the microsports.
There's so much that will be on internet
delivery done on a very personalized basis
of the sport, even though it's, you know,
the game is on at 4 p.m.
And everybody is watching at the same
time.
The experience people get can be enhanced
a lot through personalization.
So I think they'll be a lot of, you know,
great worked on the,
the internet for sports.
Obviously, there's watch ESPN and,
you know, something you wanna carry it
anywhere.
That's the first step.
>> Right.
>> And do you think people will be
watching on TVs or
do you think they'll be watching on
tablets or PCs or phones?
>> Who cares?
>> Do you think they'll be watching in
groups or alone?
>> I mean, you know, I, again if it's an
Android Tv or an Android tablet, you know.
So think of the future TV as just a very
large iPad, you know?
It'll be, you know, two meters big and it
will cost $1000.
I mean, it's gonna be, you know, the,
the cost of the semiconductors in screens
is getting less and less.
And so it'll, you know, it, it, it,
there's not gonna be a TV
market separate from the phone market and
tablet market and laptop market.
You know, they'll have similar operating
systems similar interaction patterns.
You know, a lot of the time,
you'll use your mobile phone as the remote
control for life.
You know, your mobile phone will be how
you open your car.
It'll be, you know, how you control
temperatures in your house.
Many of you are doing this already.
But these will be very mainstream things
in 10 or
20 years and it'll be how you choose
content.
You know, you'll choose and
then just flick it to the big screen but
in a lot of ways.
So you, you won't care this screen size
per se, anymore than you care about,
you know, a 5 inch iPhone is different
from a 4 inch or-
>> Mm-hm.
So let's talk about the nature of content.
So one of the things you said is you think
a lot of the content will be consumed on
a on demand, on demand basis.
So what does that mean for, how do you
think things evolve from an ad
supported model to a subscription model
and talk a little more about that?
>> Yeah.
I mean,
we're like HBO in that we're no-ads,
there'll be other people that are more
like AMC or FX that have ads.
so, you know, there's a mix of different
business models and preferences and
everyone will segment a little bit.
so, you know, YouTube, Hulu, et cetera
will do the, the ad supported part.
But, you know, the main thing is that,
you, whether it's ad supported or on us,
it's not a programmer choosing, you know,
you can watch this show Thursday at 7
o'clock.
>> Mm-hm.
>> That model, you know, is, is going away
for movies and TV shows.
>> How about the, how about the cost of
content development?
You know, in some sense, it's kind of the
golden age for scripted television, but
the, but the price tags are, are becoming
enormous.
I mean, I heard today that Gotham was $15
million to do the pilot or,
or A Game of Thrones is like $12 million
an episode.
I mean, where, where do you think that
slows down and, and is it, will it
continue and how do you think about it as
you green light new, new series?
>> Roughly, what was Ava, what your sense
of Avatar's budget?
>> 600 million.
>> Okay.
So by two hours.
>> Yeah.
>> So we're, there's so
much room to go in TV.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH] Okay.
So, you know, when, you know,
the entertainment business is a business
of spectacle.
And the budget to answer your questions,
will, in TV it will go up and up and up.
Because there's global distribution,
there's bigger prize.
There's a bigger, you know, there's only
so
many brands, some one in Switzerland is
gonna get to watch.
And to think about, I know about that, you
know, show brand and I want to see it.
And if you want to be one of those, then
you know,
having enormity of talent of the set, you
know, the,
the level of quality that goes in to House
of Cards or Game of Thrones.
You know, just continue to rise.
>> Hm.
And how do you think about Over the Top?
Are you, do you think about it as
something separate or
do you, it, it, does it factor into how
Netflix thinks about,
you know how it delivers its experience or
what kind of content it delivers?
>> Yeah, we just think about it as
internet.
You know, so if you're a current TV guy,
you like to feel like you've got
a fortress and then these bastards are
coming over the top of the wall.
but, you know, for
us, it's just creating a great experience
on an internet connected screen.
Whether that's a phone, a tablet, a
laptop, you know, or
a, a television screen.
>> so, as you look into the future, who,
who do you consider are your, your
friends?
And who are the people who are maybe less
then friends?
>> Well let's see the interesting part is
less then friends.
So we have supplier type battles with ISPs
Comcast, et cetera.
Because they say, we should help pay for
the network and
we say, well why don't you pay for our
content?
And then like that and so they're used to
getting paid and we don't want to pay.
So, you know, it's a classic supplier
relationship dynamic.
Then with c, other distributors like FX or
HBO we compete.
But we like each other a lot and
then like, I subscribe to HBO, cuz I like
watching VEEP.
And so what we realized is if they have
great shows,
people with subscribe to both.
And really we don't compete against each
other so
much, we all compete for entertainment
time.
So, think what you do on a Wednesday
night.
You go home and, you know, what do you do
to relax?
You know, you can drink a bottle of wine
or you could watch Netflix or
you could watch a DVD or you could watch
something on iTunes or
watch something on cable or watch
something on Hulu or play a board game.
You know, or like a hundred other things.
So all of that is entertainment time.
We compete for some little bit of that.
Enough to justify, you know, 9 bucks a
month.
So we don't notice it when competitors do
something and the reason is we
don't notice it in terms of our growth,
because we're all competing for
this huge pool of entertainment time and a
huge pool of disposable income.
There's no separate market for
the share of internet delivered video
compared to cable.
I mean, the customer doesn't care.
They're looking relaxation, entertainment
and video gaming.
I mean, we compete actively, you know,
with that in the loose sense of
a substitution for unwind time and or in
that case, freedom from boredom.
>> Does that mean that maybe you go into
other media types?
>> We just, so far movies and TV shows,
which is a lean back, enjo,
get wrapped up in the story experience has
been our sweet spot.
And when we think about expanding beyond
it, we're like, wow, movies and
TV shows is so big.
I mean, on a global basis, there should
be, you know,
a couple billion people who are interested
in that and we're only at 50 million.
And we have a fraction of all shows and,
and movies.
So we're much better off just staying in
what we do and making it much much bigger.
And getting to many more shows, many
members around the world.
And if we're only the movie and TV show
brand in 20 years and
we're not the sports brand, we're not
something else,
that's still on a global basis, that's a
phenomenally large market.
>> Would you ever get into sports?
>> I don't think so.
Too expensive, too hard no differential
confidence.
>> Mm-hm.
Okay.
who, as you look at the, the, the future
and you, the, do you think that,
that what, what are, are, are the, is, is
the cable bundle gonna continue or
do you see increasing disaggregation the
way you're starting to see it,
you know, happening now?
>> The likely case is that it's mostly
stays aggregated and drifts.
It's about a 100 million in the US, it's
been a 100 million for
the last three years.
And then it goes, you know, 98 and a half,
97, you know?
[COUGH] Ticks down, if you think of
broadcast like ABC.
They've gone down 2 or 3% points every
year for 30 years and
they've managed the cost and it's still a
great business economically.
It's less impactful on society, but it's a
great business.
So think of that as the likely case as
more and
more young people in particular live an
internet life.
>> Right.
So on a personal basis who do you,
you know, there are a lot of people who
look up to you and everybody says well,
we're the Netflix of x, the Netflix of y,
and who do you look up to?
I mean, as you were kind of coming up, who
were your person heroes?
>> Well, interestingly,
in the you mentioned in the startup Cohera
[UNKNOWN] that I worked at when I was 28.
And I worked so hard as an engineer
writing code,
you know, there every night all night kind
of thing.
How hard can you push?
You know,
I would build up over time on my desk this
kind of gross set of coffee cups.
And then you know, now and then, the
janitor would clean them all.
And I learned that if I just waited long
enough, I didn't have to clean them,
you know, the janitor would do that.
[LAUGH] And one morning, I came in really
early to work,
you know, five in the morning and I walk
into the bathroom and
there are all my cups being cleaned and I
looked up and it was our CEO.
Barry Clothman was cleaning them.
And so, you know, it's early in the
morning.
I'm like, I'm trying to understand the
situation,
cuz I see him there scrubbing away.
[LAUGH] So finally, I just asked him, I
was like Barry, what are you doing?
And he goes, I'm cleaning a cup.
And I was like, have you been doing it the
whole years?
Yeah.
And I'm like and you never said anything?
No.
Why?
And he said, well you work so hard and
this is the only thing I can do for you.
>> Wow.
>> And I just thought, wow, I will follow
this guy to the end of the earth and
that is exactly where he lead us.
[LAUGH] So what happened is he was an
incredibly charismatic guy
that didn't have a good market product fit
vision.
And we built an incredibly elaborate
product and
we ultimately sold one copy of it to one
customer and they never installed it.
So, you know, it's like, it's a funny
thing about leadership.
You can be very personally compelling and
high integrity, that's great.
But you also gotta lead people in the
right direction.
Not into the box canyon.
>> That's great.
I'm gonna take questions from the audience
in, in a few minutes, so
please please think of some.
So what advice do you have for young CEOs?
Just generally speaking about you started
many companies?
Just generally speaking, you know, what
advice would you have?
And then in particular, talk a little bit
about building culture and
values and when is the best time to
articulate it.
>> I would say, memorize the first 86
pages of Jim Collins's first big book,
Beyond Entrepreneurship.
Someone gave it to me in 94 and I've read
it every year since.
And the first 86 pages are absolutely
incredible.
And so that would be their, their very
practical life.
>> Well, and, and then talk a little bit
about building culture and values.
>> Yeah, I think everyone tries to build
culture and values at first, you know?
You have to stage it with a company to the
degree that you are 20 people and
you've got no revenue.
It's sort of a very implicit culture and,
you know, you spend time on,
you know, things that could kill you.
Like, you know, product to market fit and
that's appropriate.
And then, you know, later if you're going
to last, then you say, okay.
How do we, you know, make sure that as new
people come in the culture gets better.
And one of the big things is probably this
idea that you get better as
you get bigger.
So everyone implicitly has the idea that,
you know,
you start sucking as you get bigger more
political, harder to get stuff done.
And you have to actively fight acceptance
of that to come up
with very concrete examples where,
like Netflix is significantly bettering
culture than three to five years ago.
And then ten years ago and 15.
And why is, cuz we got more brains
thinking about the problem.
This is where Malthus really went wrong.
So of course, Malthus, in the late 1700s
said, everyone's gonna starve,
cuz you look at all the people growth and
you look at the fixed agriculture.
And he didn't realize that, you know,
basically as the people grew,
the ideas to improve agriculture would
also improve.
And so we've had a massive explosion in
agricultural productivity and
the ability to feed 7 billion people,
which he would be shocked by.
>> Right.
>> And it's the same thing in company
culture, which is if you have more,
you know, a thousand really thoughtful
people, thinking about how to improve,
you make more progress than if you've got
a hundred.
And so we're actually getting better as we
get bigger.
But it's constantly changing the frame of
reference,
that's really what the leader does.
You know, that this is possible and that
in fact, we should aspire to it and, and
make it happen.
>> That's great.
I don't know if there's a microphone or
going around, but
let me ask you one last question, which is
if, if you are,
we know you're going to be at Netflix for
a lot longer.
But if you were starting a new company,
what area would you look at, right now?
>> Well, that's interesting.
Well you know, if I were starting a new
company I'd probably try something in bio.
Because it's a totally different area and
it's, you know, there's, you know,
the genetic revolution, you know, for the
next, you know, hundred years.
Thinking, you know, will be incredible.
And sometime in that time period, you
know,
there'll be various kinds of post-human
life forms.
And, you know, we humans are very ego and,
and species-centric.
But, you know, it may turn out that what
gets done and, and
the races between, you know, alternative
life and augmented humanity.
And then when we could manipulate
genetics, so
that you never get a cold, you know?
It's gonna be an incredible world.
So there's, there's so much going on in,
in that world.
But, you know, I would say a, anything
that people are passionate about.
Because then each area, it's just real
exciting when you get into it.
>> Mm-hm.
Well, thank you.
I, Reid's graciously offered to take some
questions, so please.
Yeah, sir.
>> Yes, I'd to ask [INAUDIBLE].
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Well, any business can be disrupted.
If you look at Kodak, you know, it was
film images for a 100 years and
then came the digital revolution and, and
knocked them off.
And so you can be, you know, Kodak think
of this, such a shame because you've got
a brand there that represents, you know,
family and memories and
the warmth of that imagery up till 20
years ago it's been nominal.
So when we think about, you know, what's
our Kodak moment.
So there's one threat, which is streaming
goes away,
because there's some subatomic innovation.
Suddenly, you've got all content in the,
you know, and
no one does the internet anymore.
Its a post-internet world.
That seems not in the next 50 or 100
years.
Then the more material threat is, is that
movies and
TV shows become passe in society.
Kind of like novels are today, you know,
you read one a year,
it's a very small business, you know, and
then things like, Oculus and,
you know, other scenarios are incredibly
exciting and the culture's just moved on
from what our specialty is of delivering
our emotional [UNKNOWN].
So that's the one that could happen over
ten or twenty years.
But on the other hand, if we look at the
movie and
TV show market, you know, it's been a
hundred year run and
its done very well despite the rise of
video gaming over the last 20 years.
It hasn't shrunk.
So it seems to have real legs of human
story telling like that, you know,
around the fire time and it's the modern
replacement for that.
So those would be the, the two big ones
that we keep an eye on.
[NOISE] Thank you.
Thank you for the, the wonderful talk.
The question I have is, is from about five
years ago when Netflix was moving from
the DVD delivery model into the internet,
based streaming model.
[NOISE] Came up with, two plan, scheme
where you had,
899 for the internet and DVD and 799.
>> Extra episode.
>> Exactly.
Yeah.
>> Just view to the point.
[NOISE].
>> [LAUGH].
>> [COUGH].
>> [CROSSTALK] I
was one of the shareholders.
I lost-
Yeah.
A lot of value during that time.
Want to understand what was happening.
And I know
>> Yeah.
>> Netflix got a lot of backlash at that
time.
>> Yeah.
It did.
And deservedly so in hindsight.
But we were so obsessed with not being
Kodak.
You know?
With not being AOL.
With not being the company that, you know,
clung to the last dollar from its roots
that they missed the big thing.
And so, we said, you know?
We looked at, I mean, even Blockbuster was
run by very sharp people.
And so, you know, very smart managers
stick to the current models too much.
And we said, look, if,
if there's a bias, we have to be more
aggressive than we're comfortable.
Cuz smart people, which they had been,
make this mistake.
So we would have a phrase that we have to
be so aggressive it makes our skin crawl.
And so then when the idea of splitting
came up, it made our skin crawl.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But we said well,
that's what we had to be preparing for.
You know?
We're the company that's gonna be hyper
aggressive.
And in a perfect hindsight the main thing
we did wrong is
not grandfathering the pricing.
So if we had grandfathered so it wasn't an
effective price increase, it,
it would've been fine.
But we missed that.
We didn't do that.
And so there was a huge uproar because we
took 20 million US households in
the middle of the 2008 reception,
recession, and
gave them a 60% price increase.
So then the mob effect and crowd effect
kicked in.
And we, and we went from loved to hated
very quickly.
And so, you know?
In hindsight, it's kind of obvious.
Look.
Should I give 20 million people in
the middle of a recession a 60% price
increase.
You know?
No.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [COUGH] But, you know?
We were blinded by this desire to not get
trapped with DVD.
So, we got through it barely but,.
And, of course, now DVD is pretty
separate.
DVD's about 6 million members, and they
love the service.
And it's got great selection.
DVD's got some real advantages.
And then now we've got 35 million US on
streaming and
about 15 million international.
>> That's great.
yeah.
>> Reed.
One of my friends visiting from Beijing,
China, says that House of Cards is, is
wildly popular in the capital there.
And, China's becoming the second largest
movie market in the world.
Could you talk a little about your, China
strategy?
>> We're not sure, you know, if Netflix
will be able to be successful in China.
We're trying to study the issue.
The interesting one is House of Cards.
Which hopefully many of you have seen.
And it's got a Chinese storyline so
you think, oh, it doesn't make them look
that good.
And so why's it so successful?
It's because in China, this is seen as a
documentary.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And they think that our guys kill
people and, and become president.
Because that's their reality.
>> [LAUGH].
>> And so, you know?
It, the thing you see in Chinese people
about watching House of Cards is, yeah,
you're no better.
You see your people rise, and they think
it's all true.
So, you know?
You get to see what you want in, in
different shows.
So we have a lot to learn to really
understand, China.
That shows.
>> Yeah, please.
>> Well, congratulations on your award.
I'm representing an organization called
Stanford Women on Boards, which is,
as the name says, women, across the
university who are on for-profit and,
and, not-for-profit boards.
You've certainly had great success with
gender diversity.
And what advice would you give both to the
women who are on boards seeking other
boards or organizations who are looking
for great candidates for boards?
>> Yeah.
It's a super tough issue both on race and
gender.
Because the people that get recruited for
boards are people you're really
comfortable with.
And depending on your, social circle and
others, then you
don't have as many African American or
Hispanic or women executive roles.
And getting the references is really hard.
You know,I've been [COUGH] really.
I, I think I started you know, twenty
years ago as a classic Silicon Valley.
It's a meritocracy.
It'll change.
And I realize now that we need to make,
you know,
really active efforts on building the
connection that works.
Both in that case for, for in your case,
for female executives but, you know?
It's broader, obviously, than just gender.
Because it's a very intimate relationship
with the board.
And so you bring people in, that you
really, really trust.
And that takes an amount of time and
comfort and exposure.
And so, it's a, it's a deep problem,
which we'll make some progress on, with,
expanding contact networks.
Interesting is why I just joined the
Hispanic Foundation of Silicon Valley,
which is a great organization.
But, you know, what do I really know about
the challenges for
Hispanic, people in America?
Not a lot.
But I'll be a donor.
And I'll really get to know, [COUGH]
excuse me.
The board and the other members and
make an active effort to say, oh, that's a
person that could be an executive, or
a board member, or something like that, or
for my organization or for some other.
And, you know, we all need to make as much
effort as possible on that, you know,
cross, you know, sector, integration.
So check back with me in two years, and
I'll see if we've, you know,
if we're as successful on the Latino side
as we've been on the, the gender side.
>> yeah.
Sorry.
>> Thank you so much for the talk.
I have been super interested about your
culture.
So I wanna ask a question in, in that
regard.
You talked about hire quickly and openly.
You also talked about letting go pretty
quickly.
So, how do you make sure during this very
short time frame,
you ensure there's enough diversity,
enough different ideas,
so that not everybody inside looks just
the same?
yeah.
I don't think the,
we don't let people go quickly.
we, in other words, it's not like oh, one
day you wake up.
So, you know, we try to think through.
Just as you would do on a professional
sports team is, you know?
You have one bad game.
You know?
You're not out.
It's a, it's a track record you build up
over time.
And then, you know, if your leadership,
your manager or their manager and
HR think, you know, you're unlikely to
develop into the great player we need in
that position, then you do get the
package.
That's the adequate performance.
and, you know?
We try to select and we.
To answer your question,
which is how do you not weed out,
essentially, diverse ideas,.
The answer is we reward diverse ideas that
often,
prizing people who argue with me or with
others, you know, to make it safe to do.
And that, I don't think anyone would say,
oh if you disagree with senior management
that's what gets you out.
You know, we, we need to live that in
practice to make sure that
people feel safe if they're good ideas.
It doesn't mean that every idea's a good
idea.
And to the degree that you
confrontationally brought up, you know?
Twenty crazy ideas in a row, you know,
over six months?
We probably would give you a package
because it's, that, like,
not a great track record.
But again it's not an instantaneous thing.
It's over a track record.
>> Yeah.
Sorry.
Where's the mic?
Nora?
[NOISE].
>> Congratulations on your fantastic
success.
Could you talk a bit about work/life
balance, and how you make all that make-
>> My what?
Sorry.
>> Work and life balance.
>> Yeah.
Work/life balance is the wrong metaphor.
Its really work/life integration.
You know?
So the reality is, you know,
we come up with great ideas in the shower.
You know?
That's not work time.
But it is really.
And so I think each individual has to
figure out in their situation.
How do they stay healthy?
How do they have healthy relationships?
And we're super flexible on it.
We don't, we tend to use,
pretty strict about meetings, being just
during the nine to five day.
And we think of office time as time to
have physical in person meetings.
And then beyond that it's sort of how you
run your schedule is up to you,
back to the freedom and responsibility.
And ultimately we care, again, what you
get accomplished.
Not, like, do you also coach your kids'
baseball team.
Which is fine.
And so there's not,.
Because it's much more about the work as
opposed to what hours you put in,
it doesn't tend to be.
You know?
That I gotta show up at nine even though
I'm not getting much done at
night because everyone else is there and I
need to be seen.
Like a kind of investment banking type
hold scenario.
>> Sir.
>> Thank you very much.
You mentioned the, leverage that you have
from the data that you collect.
Can you talk about, a bit more about, what
kind of data, you collect?
And what insights you derive from that and
use it in the content that you create?
>> Well, we're always trying to predict,
what are you going to enjoy?
That's the, if you watch a bunch of
Netflix,
you're gonna retain and evangelize.
So if you watch three hours, you've got a
high,
a month, you've got a high churn rate.
If you watch 30 hours, it's a median churn
rate.
If you watch 100 hours on Netflix a month,
you know, you love it.
You rave about the service.
So think of it as, just as in a Google
search,
they're looking at probability,
essentially of a good click.
A click that then you didn't come back and
then click on something else cuz the first
click didn't work.
They wanted to actually solve your query.
And we have a similar one which is, did
you, how much did you watch and
did you get something you watch.
So it's trying to look for things in your
rewind behavior and
your propensity to try different things,
to continue with it.
Did you watch five episodes in a row or
just one episode?
Things like that.
They give us a, a sense of intensity and
desire.
And then that fuels algorithmic changes to
try to
figure out what are you going to enjoy
most.
So the idea is you open Netflix.
And there's, like, ten things you're just
dying to watch because we've got
the right ten things showing.
>> Interesting.
>> Last question.
>> Let's do one more question.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Somebody have a-
.
Yeah? [SOUND]. >> Your leadership has been
tested.
And you have reliably responded over a
long period of time.
Reed, if you were to say what the source
of your success as a leader is,
what would you say?
>> I'm always interested in kind of core
fundamental principles.
And I've had a good ability to not get
distracted by transitory things.
You know?
How you're supposed to be
as opposed to just being able to be myself
and the company to be able to be itself.
And, so there's a, a very strong sense of
groundedness as opposed to, let's
figure out what other people are doing or
follow the fad or that kind of thing.
So that gets you through a lot.
You know?
If you sort of
stick to the fundamentals,um, and are, are
pretty good at,
trying to avoid, well both distraction
and, you know, false profits.
>> That's fantastic.
Let me, let me end by asking you to
recommend one TV show to the audience.
>> [LAUGH] Bojack Horseman is a new show
that just came out.
And it's so darkly funny.
I, I think you would all enjoy it.
But it's, it's humor right on the edge of
social acceptability.
Like, you know, there's a joke and you're
laughing and,
like, I should not be laughing at that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So if you like that kind of thing.
It's sorta you know, like Entourage
crossed with South Park.
You know?
And it's, it's fantastic.
Thank you all.
So many of you I got to see the names
cards when I got here a little bit early.
And I recognize so many of the names.
So, it's such a treat.
I really appreciate, all of you coming
out.
And I look forward to the reception and
being with you.
>> Please join me in thanking, Reed
Hastings.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you, Reed.
>> All right.
>> Great job, sir.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE].
Thank you, Dean.
>> Congratulations.
>> This is to make up.
[APPLAUSE].
>> For the entrepreneur class I
could never get into.
>> [LAUGH].
>> You can come any time.
>> But I am, I am so happy.
[APPLAUSE]
>> To everyone here who's been part of
Netflix, it's a joint amazing effort
that's, just such an adventure.
So thank you for coming tonight.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]